premières images en preuve en provenance
de téhéran ce matin les premiers
manifestants se rassemblant dans les
rues de la capitale iranienne en février
2010 il est 8h à paris 10h30 à téhéran
pour l'instant les télés françaises donc
ça à se mettre sous la dent des images
d'état iranienne montrant des
manifestants pro-régime
mais les contestataires du mouvement
vers eux aussi manifeste aujourd'hui
leur voix arrive bien jusqu'à paris où
chabé journaliste iranienne exilée
depuis 6 heures ce matin ils guettent
les nouvelles du pays il ya des gens qui
sont dans la roue maintenant et il
envoie pas des images par portable voici
ce sont des gens qui étaient dans la
roue à des choses vers ce matin ce
matériel bush avait son mari ont 35 ans
de journalisme derrière eux lui a passé
plus de six ans enfermé et torturé dans
les geôles du régime
menacé une fois de trop en 2003 ils ont
atterri à paris dans leur appartement à
créteil elle tire la rédaction en chef
de rosen line site d'information
consulter chaque semaine par près de 4
millions d'internautes dans le monde
mais depuis que l'iran s'est enfoncée
dans la crise son travail c'est
compliqué les trois quarts de ses
correspondants la barre ont été enfermés
bonjour aux gars est vraiment crise
triste tous ces gens ils sont en prison
mais elle était à l'aps choyés en
prison' lâcher et semoy élire en prison
et
beaucoup des jeunes en cachette j'aurais
pu être votre situation ça exactement
[Musique]
alors
depuis les dernières manifestations de
décembre qui ont fait 10 morts la
surveillance d'état en iran s'est accru
au téléphone elle tente d'obtenir des
nouvelles d'un dignitaire religieux
sympathisants du mouvement vert
il a dit comme sur une houle il est en
voyage son fils est en voyage et jeudi
est ce que vous savez comment on m'a dit
que je sais pas j'ai pas contacter je ne
sais pas ils ne sont pas là vous savez
la mesure où ça veut dire qu il est ils
ont peur de me répondre
ils se sentent sur écoute ou fruit
[Musique]
des coups de fil comme celui là sont
monnaie courante
le meilleur canal pour faire passer
l'info reste encore le net il est midi
les agences officielles parlent de
plébiscite pro gouvernementales mais la
boîte mail de nouch abbey révèle une
toute autre version les supporters de
moussavi l'un des principaux leaders de
l'opposition sont dans la rue et zone là
il zones à bas la dictature
il a commencé à marcher vers la place
azadi mais ils ont été arrêtés par la
police des polices ils ont tiré
directement aux gens il ya quelques
jours qui est qui et
touché on ne sait pas si son nom vous
pas la crise en iran c'est avant tout la
guerre de l'info l'un des bastions
occidentaux du mouvement vert se trouve
ici dans l'appartement de mona il est
15h sur son ordinateur parviennent les
premières images de la face cachée de
cette journée de manif on regarde et
venez voir
vous voyez ça c'est une vidéo qui vient
d'apparaître en ligne at-elle tenu sur
un contact qu'on a identifié avec qui on
travaille
alors les crises afin de se pourvoir
dans quelques heures ces images seront
reprises par les principales td
européenne mona travaille chez elle
bénévolement comme une agence de presse
analyste financière d'origine iranienne
elle a pris sa journée de congé pour
assurer sa permanence elle traduit les
textes et récolte les vidéos d'une arme
et d'anonymes en iran les documents
qu'elle transmet après vérification à
toutes les grandes rédactions
s'étend de métro écrit des stores en
saas et la vidéo tout le monde a repris
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça
c'est aujourd'hui
mais de la matière pour les ponts les
journalistes
de la matière il y en a encore faut-il
déjouer la censure
pour cacher au monde ces images l'état
iranien a multiplié les cyber attaques
contre les sites d'opposition et couper
internet durant plusieurs heures
18 heures nous quittons le qg de mona
pour rejoindre la diaspora iranienne
réunis dans un froid glacial place saint
michel
parmi les manifestants nous chabbey
notre journaliste réfugié qui vient
juste de lâcher son ordinateur
maintenant qu'on parle il ya des gens
qui sont dans la roue dans tous les
plats se terrant isolerait uni est
en train de donner beaucoup de slogans
contre le gouvernement
tous ici se sont tenus au courant heure
par heure de 7 à 77 ans ils sont passés
maîtres dans l'art des
télécommunications vous avez des
nouvelles de la famille part
je fais des cats aujourd'hui je suis
beaucoup moins au courant d'informations
qui passe en france ici qu'est ce qui se
passe là bas c'est concrètement
psychologiquement en vie là-bas la
télévision iraniens ils ont montré ce
qu'il voulait mais de toutes façons de
les iraniens ils sont au courant de tout
ici sales et nous voyons tous
heureusement il ya les meilleurs
journalistes le peuple iranien
[Applaudissements]
il est 20 heures pendant que les
iraniens de paris entonnent un chant de
fraternité leurs images sont diffusées
dans tous les jt cette semaine là en
iran le gouvernement a procédé à près
d'un millier d'arrestations et il laisse
encore planer le doute quant à la
disparition de certains protestataires
la diaspora iranienne devra garder la
connexion avec le pays pour que le sort
de ses proches restent au coeur de
l'information